>> Hi. I'm Eric Durand. I'm a
computational biologist here at 23andMe. I've been with
the company for about two years now and
I'm mostly working on their ancestry products which
run from a variety of different problems. Before
that I was a postdoc at UC Berkeley
for another two years, and even before that I was a PhD student in France. And
yeah, that's who I am.
>> Great, well, at this point in the
lesson, we've been learning a lot about how to
connect the dots in our genome to figure out
ancestry. And we've learned a little bit about identity
by state, where we can sort of match
snvs to four comparisons. And we've just learned a
little bit about identity by descent. or IBD. And,
what we really want to know from a, a computational
biologist is, how do you determine IBD or identity by descent?
>> Yeah, so first maybe we should define exactly what IBD, or identity
by descent is. So IBD is something that refers to a chunk of continuous
DNA. And we say that two individuals share a chunk of DNA identical
by descent if this chunk has been
inherited through a common ancestor without recombination.
It means that you inherited these segments from
the common ancestor however far back it was in
the past and it was never broken by a
recombination event. During meiosis. So if you want the
simplest example of, of identity by descent maybe
is between the parent and his child, where because
of the way, if I refer you back to
a high school biology, because of the way chromosomes
are inherited, a child will inherit one chromosome exactly from each of
his parents. And so, a child is 50% identical by descent with
his parent. And in this, in this case, a common ancestor is
a parent, himself. And the child is 50% IBD with, with the parent.
>> And so, it doesn't matter how big the segment is. The segment
could be the whole length of the
chromosome, itself, or anything shorter than that?
>> Exactly. So
if you only look one generation back in time,
the, the segment will cover a full chromosome in
the child. The full chromosome in the child would
be identical by descent with this parent. If you go
one more generation with, with a, a child is
about 25% IBD with each of his four grandparents. But
there already, the 25% is only approximate. And it
can vary, you can be more IBD, you can share
more IBD with one grandparent than with
another. Just because of the way recombination occurs.
>> I see. So there may be an average, re-, an average IBD. But it doesn't have
to be exact. Because, like you said, the
recombination doesn't happen in the same place every time.
>> Exactly. And also because of our ability to detect it, there is some error,
some statistical error around the estimation of IBD,
which in the end, will lead to slightly differences
[SOUND]
time and the more variation between this person changes
segments become
[SOUND]
relate IBD and IBS
serves the reccomendation process. It would be great if
[INAUDIBLE]
tells us where this is where recommendation occurs but
[SOUND]
even worse, we don't even know the genealogy at least
[INAUDIBLE]
things that are closely related, their second cousin, most people just ignore
[INAUDIBLE].
We don't know how
[SOUND].
Which is IDS, identity by states.
You can definitely detect segments between individuals that are
[INAUDIBLE]
so this is
[SOUND]
IDB algorithm works. We start by
[INAUDIBLE]
long segments of IBS, and that gives us some kind of candidate pool of IDB
segments, and then we apply vice filters.
From these sets to extract the IBD segments
>> hmm
>> And those filters are varied. They depend
on the length of the segments meaning that it's
pretty unlikely to have a very long IBS
segment that was not generated by a common ancestor.
We have we also have an applied filter for the frequency of the segment that
was. Inherited. If the segment is very,
very frequent in the population, maybe it's not
IBD, it's just IBS and that arose to, to being fixed in the population because
maybe of natural selection or other reasons. So
frequency, quality of the segment. If it contains
many mutations, then it's unlikely to be IBD. We have a lot of filters.
>> Yeah, it sounds like you really have to think a lot around how
to make sure that it's a true identity by descent, and not, like you
say, either coincidental or something else. So
let me make sure I even understand
this. The smaller the segment that, the
smaller the segment that appears to be commonly
shared the more likely it could be that it's just, you know,
a match of identity by say, by chance with someone random in the population.
>> That's correct. So maybe I should clarify the definition of IBD
a little bit, because under the definition I gave, actually everyone is
IBD everywhere. Just because we all have a common ancestor if we
go back far enough back in time. So when we talk about IBD,
we usually restrict ourself to the recent past. Say, I don't know, a few tens of
generations, maybe 1,000 years. And what, what's beyond this point we,
we're, we just don't have the power to decide anymore if it's IBD or
not. But if you go, if you look small enough everyone is IBD everywhere.
>>
how difficult are these algorithms to write
actually you know essentially predict or infer IBD?
>> So they're pretty sophisticated now, and difficulty comes mostly
from the fact that these algorithms need to be fast.
So the main computational challenge with IBD is that the
problem is fundamentally quadratic, meaning that we want to compare
all pairs of individuals within our data set. It's fine
probably if you're in an academic setting and you study,
you have your one-off analysis and you have one or
2,000 individuals and you just want to computer IBD once.
You're okay with letting your computers run for months and
then you have your result and you'll have it. But
in a setting like the one we have here at
23andMe, first we have others of my age and more
of individuals. We have more than 300,000 individuals now
in the database. And we need to recompute IBD
every time we have new customer who come in.
So every day, we have new customers coming in,
and we need to compute IBD permanently on the
fly with them. So we really need to think
a lot of how to make this algorithm faster.
So that is as far as difficulties, that's purely computational.
And the second difficulty is more, I would
say, algorithmic, where we need to find ways
without compromising the speed of the algorithm to
make it as accurate as possible. And the
good thing for the second point is that
we have pretty sophisticated way now of testing
the algorithm. So, of course and algorithm is
going to make mistakes, that's guaranteed. But we can
assess the rate at which it makes mistakes. Pretty,
pretty well now through either simulations in which we simulate
the pedigree, and so we know we know exactly which
segments are IBD because that's the way we run the
simulations, or through pedigrees that our customers report to
us. So customers can tell us who their parents are
in the database, who their first cousins are in the
database. And so we can compare the prediction of our
algorithm to the known truth, and that gives us
a good sense of how accurate the algorithms are.
>> That's amazing, and it does sound sophisticated. what about Mis, user
mistakes that if someone thinks they know who their father is and.
>> That.
>> It turns out not to be true.
>> Yes. That definitely happens. we trust the law of large
number I guess. And so because we have lots of people reporting
their, their pedigrees and we guess that you know, not everything is wrong,
and we can still extract a lot of, it's still a very powerful dataset.
We have other ways of checking whether someone is really the kin of
someone without doing IBDs. There is some more obvious stuff that you can do.
>> So this isn't just a static feature that you work
on. I mean, its constantly changing, you're always having to work on
it or update it?
>> We do, we're updating it now, but we definitely try to minimize the number
of times we need to update the features. Not because it's not fun to develop new
algorithm, but because of the cost of recomputing.
Every time we change the algorithm, we don't
have just to do this incremental update for
new customers, but we have to recompute everything.
>> All 300,000.
>> All three, and it's still,
even with fast algorithm, we're still talking about
months. And months and months after that sometime.
>> Where do you get your computing power? I
mean, as a non-computer science or coding or statistical or
math person. How much, I mean can you relate
to me how much computing power we're talking about here?
>> So, in production they have their own
cluster that computes for new customers, and I'm
not too sure how big it is. In research we also have our, our own cluster,
it's about 120 CPU's, so
it's not huge it is definitely challenging to run very,
very large scale experiments on this cluster.
And my guess is that soon we'll have
to go to the cloud to where we're
actually talking to Google compute engineers to be
able to compute IBD on their machines. Just because it will scale much better.
>> What happens if you get, I don't know, three
million people? Will you break the, the system, will it,
do you foresee it getting a point where so many
people participate that the computational power isn't, isn't high enough?
>> It's definitely hard to keep up with the growth
of the database, but it's doable. And the fact
that we build our algorithms to be incremental means that
it's pretty easy for us to separate. The customers
into smaller batches and run, and run on each batch.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, and get the job done but, yeah.
>> Well you know, speaking sort of more on the computational side of things
I want you to talk to us for
a minute about what, what computational biology is sort of
all about, I mean, you have a particular a
job at 23andMe, which you seem to really like.
>> Mm-hm.
>> but to, let's say budding geneticists, young, young,
middle or old people you know, interested in genetics
and looking for maybe a job or career change.
What is it about computational biology that's appealing or useful?
>> Well, so, a computational biologist, I
think is always someone who is trying to
develop or at least who implements computational methods
to analyze biological data. So in, in my
field, in genetics, even in my field, there is a wide variety of different data.
And a wide variety of different applications. So,
a computational biologist could be someone developing pipeline
to analyze whole genome sequences, for example. Just from the raw data to the
alignment to culling the SNVs from the raw data and
just process the data so it's ready for statisticians, for example, to try to.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Further process it. Could be someone like me, who's, for me a
very bad, very big part of my job is machine learning. So it
could be someone who's really interested in
machine learning and trying to extract sense from
the data indirectly. it comes from the, from
the realization I think that the amount of
genetic data is huge and growing really fast.
And even maybe more problematic is the complexity
of the data, like any single phenotype is
going to be influenced by, not any single
but many many phenotypes, is going to be influenced by a lot of different
genes. It's very, very hard to find exactly the structure in the data. So
[INAUDIBLE]
is, is one way to, to tackle the problem. I,
and I think it's a way that's proved successful already.
So, yeah.
>> And it sounds, you know? Based on what you're saying that, you know?
The information age is just growing bigger
and bigger, especially in the world of genetics.
>> hm.
>> So the need for understanding and the need for people
who can actually use this information and this data is really important.
>> Yeah.
>> how many, hm, how often do you
find the biologists, the trained geneticists or biologists understand
enough coding or computer science to move forward
versus how often is it that it's the math
and computer science people who are learning the
biology to help out, which direction is it normally?
>> So, here at 23andMe, I think it's safe
to say that all the computational biologists came from
the computer side of things. They have training either
in computer science, or in math, or in statistics.
And they learn biology later as
fascinating application field for data scientist basically.
>> And so as you know, biology in genetics
grows, you will think there will be a an opportunity
for many more computational individuals who are interested to
sort of learn genetics and biology and, and apply that?
>> Yes, definitely. I think,
I honestly think that biology is a
science of the 21st century, nothing less. And
it will change everything for most people.
It will revolutionize medicine. Being preventive or, or
personalized. It will yeah it will basically
change the daily life of, of everyone I
guess. And we need more people, and I think many, many more jobs are going
to be created around, around you know computational biology.
>> can you talk to us maybe a bit about
just in general the type of coding you've done while you
worked for 23andMe, even beyond 23andMe? you mentioned that you've worked on
the ancestry. And specifically IBD, are there other aspects that
you've worked on as well?
>> So I developed another feature of 23andMe called
Ancestry Composition which goal is to find the origin of
segments. Not as precise of finding who you share it with, but
where does it come from, so it could come from some part Europe, it could come
from some part of East Asia, or some part of Africa. So here it's, we apply
very, very different methods. The type of coding there was very
much the machine learning type of coding. So it's a lot of numerical
analysis where you're trying to predict classes for your data.
So it's a lot of, you, you end up developing a lot of optimization problems.
A lot of dynamic programming is involved in
these kind of, of problems. For example, when
you code a hidden markov model to
relate adjacent adjacent chunks of DNA, then there
is some very well-known dynamic program that you
need to implement to make this thing fast.
And to be able to optimize it to fit your data as well as possible.
>> hm. How do you think the future of biology and genetics looks with regards
to computer science and computational biology? Do you think there's going to be
a big need for geneticists in general and people who study biology to learn
these skills as they go along, or do you think they're just going to need
to partner up with other people who know them?
>>
I think you could defend both point, point
of view obviously. I think there is still
a lot of value for being a specialist
in your field. Obviously, you cannot be good
at everything and, I think good biologists and good geneticists can
give people with a strong computational background, you know, hints
at what they should be looking at, and advice on what
is important in field, what is the problems
we need to solve first is definitely very
vaulable. So I think there is room for,
there is still room for pure biologists, definately.
>> Well, tell us a bit more about in your background,
I mean how did you get interested, I mean, well first,
I should ask, how did you get here, what did you
study in school and how did you get interested in it?
>> so my undergrad was in applied math and computer science,
and then I went on to do a PhD in statistics. And because the way, that was
in France, and because the way it works in
France, I had to choose a field of application
for statistics. And that's, only then that I began
to think about genetics. Because my PI was very
interested in population genetics which is this field in
genetics where we try to learn about human evolution,
so natural selection, demography, ancestry, identity
by descent so then I became interested
as well, and I developed statistical learning
method to learn about the genetic structures
of populations. After my PhD, I decided to do a postdoc here at UC
Berkeley because I had a very good opportunity with someone very famous in
the field of population genetics. And there I was lucky
enough to work on the first draft of the neanderthal genome.
>> Wow.
>> So I actually had the first fully enacted genome sitting on my
hard drive, and I could just do my stuff with it, anything I wanted.
>> That's awesome.
>> And I contributed to develop methods that,
that estimated the amount of neanderthal DNA that modern
humans have today so that was a pretty fascinating project.
>> So, no big deal, right? No big deal.
[LAUGH]
>> It was. I think it was a pretty big deal because it changed the view
of people in the fields like before, before
2010 most people would, including me probably would have
said no, neanderthal is a strictly distinct species.
It never contributed any DNA to modern humans. Just
was extinct for some reason. And didn't give
any trace. And now we know that's probably not
true and that left few percent.
>> That's a pretty exciting project to work on.
>> Yeah. And then, I always knew about 23andMe, I've known about them
since it started almost in 2008. And so, when I
was there, I was local, and so I knew it was
a good opportunity to apply. And so there was this job opening,
they were advertising for a computational biologist position.
At first, I didn't know exactly what it implied.
And so I sent my CV, was interviewed
and got the job. since then, it's been amazing.
>> And here you are.
>> Yeah.
>> so it sounds like you had a major interest in You know, basic
math, a love for math and computation, you know which sort of blossomed
into you know an applied, or an
application in biology. If there was somebody watching
this interview right now, and they're really intrigued
about how biology, and computer science and math,
statistics work together in an a particular job.
What advice would you give them to, to
study in school? What would you recommend that
they do? Or maybe where would you recommend
that they seek, you know career advice or, or, or work?
>> Yeah so as I said, I do believe there is needs for specialists.
So I do recommend they keep studying math and computer science and statistics
a lot. But they still need to take some biology. At the very least
to figure what are the problems that we need to solve today in biology.
And how to relate. You know, it's not enough
to get out of school, and know list of
the ten fastest algorithm for each specific problem that
you learned in school. You also need to be able
to relate those great class of algorithms to different
problems in biology. How you will need to adapt them.
How sometimes you have to realize there is nothing
that exists already and you need to develop something that's
not going to be optimal, probably, but you need to do the first part
of the problem. So you do need to know enough biology, at the very
least, to understand the problems. Otherwise, for
example, for ancestry, if you don't have
a very clear understanding of the recombination
process, there is nothing you can do.
>>
[LAUGH]
. You need, you need to understand exactly what probabilistic model you can put
behind meiosis. How often it's going to break
a chromosome, or these things. So you
do need to know enough biology to
understand the problems, definitely. So you need
to take at least an intro to biology class or something at the very least.
>> So for someone who is interested you know,
kindle that passion for computer science and math but
you know, also pay attention on biology class
>> Uh-huh. Yeah, and yeah, and just, I guess just
do it. I think it's, I think it's the most exciting
field for data scientist to be in now. It's just
growing amazingly fast, and it's already changed a lot of things.
>> I want to ask you two more questions. We'll edit these
back a little bit, because I want that to be sort of
how we close. I want to know, what's probably, what's
one of the best moments of being you and
having your job. Like, what's one of the, the
most positive parts or most exciting moments you've had?
>> so I'm lucky at 23andMe, because I have both a foot in research and a foot
in product. And I think the most satisfying moment is when you pool your
research to make a product out of it, and
when you see customers start to use it. And then
you know, if you're interested in science, and you publish
a very good paper, you're super lucky, you get a
thousand citations, its already, you can have a lifetime achievement.
But here, if you put, if you make a product
out of your research it's going to be seen by
hundreds of thousand of people instantly, and they're going to react
about it, they're going to talk about it, they're going to give
you new ideas about it, they're going to find bugs you never
thought you had in the first place. Because 300,000 pairs of eyes,
you know, it's much more than yours. So that's definitely very satisfying.
>> And what would you say is probably one of
the most difficult or challenging aspects of what you do?
>> that's a good question.
I guess, testing is probably the hardest.
Yeah, everyone believes they are write good code,
everyone believes their code is fast. But
not everyone tests enough, especially when you're in
a production setting where you're going to
put a lot of stress on your algorithm,
so the most difficult part I think is to make sure everything works as intended.
There is no, it's going to stay fast,
you're going to, you need to have very good
understanding of you know, the algorithm complexities, the algorithmic
complexities of what you code just to make sure
you're not going to receive an email on
Sunday saying oh you broke the website or we're
losing a lot of money, fix it. So, yeah, you need to test a lot, I would say.
>> Great,
well thank you Eric for joining us.
>> Thanks Matt.